what did you think about the apology
video
um I thought it was very well crafted
and I think the his supporters very much
appreciated it and a lot of them were
like we don't care [ __ ] it it doesn't
matter but I do think that some of the
stuff in there that was mentioned was a
little bit of a
a little bit of a hedge to justify like
oh yeah people are have mental health
issues and are killing themselves so I
took Peds like you know to build this
more viral brand to then get my message
out to the masses further to help the
people who are suicidal but and because
I also have mental issues like he
mentions his insecurity and whatnot but
it's like is you building this character
that is unachievable naturally helping
body image issues for men 100
[ __ ] infinitely worse but essentially
he's causing the low self-esteem that he
claims he's here to support yeah and
then it's also it would be one thing if
there was no monetary upside to it but
for him to continue to hammer that my
businesses grow 50 year over year
without my without my push it's like
[ __ ] off like there's no chance his
physique was created to sell supplements
right that's why it was that it was
premeditated now his self-esteem may
play into this this you know a lot of
businesses are like a commercial
manifestation of the person right like
your businesses have a bit of Derrick in
them or a lot of Derek in them because
they're like your philosophy infuses
into them uh but yeah you can't claim
that your physique has got nothing to do
with creating a boatload of money for
yourself it's in the email yeah like
it's in the [ __ ] email there yeah and
it's like while I I do totally
understand the the benefits of trt and
you know HRT and having proper medical
oversight Etc like some of the the
justifications for like Deca and
Winstrol and stuff that is clearly only
included to enhance your image to
like in your 40s there's nothing
ancestral or conducive to longevity
about adding in Winstrol like let's be
[ __ ] honest so
um when he said it didn't help it's just
like well what was the desired outcome
of it to begin with well can you not
support people through depression
without taking a metric [ __ ] ton of gear
like is that not is that not possible
like I'm helping you not kill yourself
by taking a Winstrol oh
man well what do you think about the
apology dude
that man is like a WWE star yeah to me I
the the Cadence of the speech it was
obviously heavily prepared and maybe
even entirely scripted I think there's
one Arrow throughout the whole thing
um the whole like [ __ ] movements and
the pointing to the sky and these sort
of
um pre-prepared little routines of words
to me are not what an apology video is
supposed to be about he doesn't seem
sorry he doesn't seem sad there is no
part of vulnerability in that it seems
unbelievably performative to me and you
could say
um that is part of his personality maybe
that's just the Cadence and like the way
that he speaks and stuff I'm prepared to
accept that but
I didn't feel sympathy for him and I
feel sympathy
um other YouTubers do apologies and I'm
like yeah fair enough uh all of the
caveats when it came to
um this is to do with self-esteem the
immediate misdirection toward four
thousand men a day kill themselves and
eight eighty thousand men a day try to
take their own lives and stuff like that
it's like bro no one no one criticized
you about that no one even brought that
up yeah
um
he also said it's complicated
do you think it's complicated no not
really
you took drugs like you were called out
for taking drugs and lying about it yeah
that's the complication I would
understand the complication if he was on
therapeutic replacement and that was it
from day one and he didn't want people
to think that his therapeutic
replacement was something that everyone
needed if they were following a good
lifestyle diet Etc and there wasn't
monetary upside to what he was doing and
there wasn't this like lying to their
faces and all this stuff but it was just
yeah it was uh I don't know like the
apology was not some of the stuff he
said was good he said I [ __ ] up very
clearly and acknowledged what he did
um you know some of it was great for
sure you got you got maybe 30 seconds of
that yeah before twice being told how
rich he was and then again misdirection
into the number of people that are
trying it's like dude it's on your
shoulders yeah this wasn't in service of
anything that was outside of your
control like you're the person that
chooses how what happens with your
business you're the person that chooses
what happened happens with your
self-esteem you're the person that's
controlling the inputs and outputs that
you have within your own life you're not
even restricted monetarily or in terms
of resources you can't even say you know
I needed the money it's like you said in
second 25 of the video that you were
Rich before you even started doing this
yeah like this was completely elective
right
um yeah but at the beginning he says I
[ __ ] up like I own this
I thought it was a really bad move to
not put it on his Instagram in full I
think it was incredibly contrived to
take the most vague
portion of the video that is on YouTube
clip that put it as a reel on Instagram
and if people didn't know about the
story it gives him culpable deniability
and it doesn't sort of stries and affect
the problem any further and then the
YouTube channel that only has like 200
000 Subs I mean the video's done two mil
by the time that we're speaking which is
a lot but
if he put it on his Instagram uh story
shares extra exposure that's his primary
platform of growth but he didn't put the
full video on there well why it's not
because of platform limitations it's
because he didn't want the exposure yeah
I think longer videos you can have it in
real formats though right like it's
still the exact same push as a short
video and yeah that's definitely notable
I don't know like I definitely think his
Brands Will Survive and I think he will
uh you know continue to have his
followers that are
um like ultimately a lot of the stuff he
does talk about is positive and I do
think people would benefit from some of
the things he preaches but it's just I
don't know the way he calculated this
out meticulously and went about
deceiving people was just hard to wrap
your head around
as a Justified move at the end of the
day what's happening people
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]